Super Bowl 50 has arrived to San
Francisco and the city is turnt up even
though the actual game is happening
about an hour away in Santa Clara but
here in San Francisco we have Super Bowl
City home to week-long festivities
catering to the 1 million fans who
flocked here but the thing is all of
this fun comes with a huge price tag
about 5 million dollars for extra public
services like security and
transportation funded almost exclusively
by San Francisco's taxpayers not fair
don't like it not comfortable with it
and it sucks it's Harley once once in a
lifetime probably I'm fine with it but I
like sports if you don't like sports I
can see how you probably would be more
pissed off about it it's fresh because
there's definitely a lot more that it
can be going to now get this the Super
Bowl host committee agreed to reimburse
the city of Santa Clara where the game
is being held for all of its costs
that's nearly three point six million
dollars but San Francisco is only
getting back a tiny fraction of the
nearly 5 million dollars it's spending
and that's something that some public
officials are not ok with in fact i've
heard the NFL say what's five million
dollars it's not that much money well it
may not be a lot to one of the
wealthiest companies in our country but
it's certainly a lot to our residents
that live on the streets to our
working-class and middle-class families
that are struggling to live here in San
Francisco that don't want to see their
services cut during this week the NFL is
a giant moneymaker and the most valued
sports league in the world last year it
made more money than San Francisco's
entire fiscal year budget sure it's a
big deal for the Bay Area to host the
biggest sporting event of the year the
critics say that taxpayers shouldn't be
subsidizing this corporate spectacle or
pay for a bunch of rich people partying
all week keep in mind the average cost
for a Super Bowl ticket this year is a
whopping five thousand dollars and the
average daily rate for a hotel room in
the city this week has doubled so you
gotta ask is all the money flowing into
the city helpful
the mayor's office says it expects to
make up all the costs through increased
taxes on hotels and other sales and the
Super Bowl host committee claims that
host cities see an economic boost of
about five hundred million dollars but
one study found that the actual economic
impact is only about a tenth of that
claim which would really suck
considering San Francisco has a deficit
all right it's pretty exciting that the
Super Bowl is here but at the end of the
day who should really be footing the
bill